what's the punch line the punch line is
that we need to have more conversations
with our kids about money because
there's a direct connection between
talking about money and teaching kids
all of the good values we want to
imprint in their silly little brains
before we shove them out into the world
do you think we were taught about money
when we were kids and it's just not
happening today or it's never happened I
think there was much less talking about
money when we were younger I think many
of our questions were sort of brushed
away as something that was age
inappropriate or even impolite something
that you didn't talk about not just with
people who were not blood-related oh I
maybe I'm confused i thought you meant
here's how to save money here's how to
open an account here's a passbook are
you saying we should be telling our kids
here's how much money I make here's how
much I'm struggling so the practical
tips and the tools the how to do
allowance and how to think about
smartphones that comes as a result of
the questions that kids ask it from the
very beginning so the first time they
often handle money is when the Tooth
Fairy comes and they want to know well
this is great what can i buy with it and
how can I get some more money and then
you begin with the allowance and it sort
of goes from there if you talk to your
kids about money the right way what
happens 10 years from now how does their
behavior change versus what they might
otherwise become here's what we have to
worry about that we didn't have to worry
about quite as much even a decade ago
but certainly 20 or 30 years ago which
is that we've got 16 and 17 year olds
making six-figure decisions about
college as they approach the question of
how to pay for college and whether to
take on tens of thousands of dollars of
student loan debt these are teenagers
making these decisions it's lunacy but
it's the reality that we're dealing with
and so they need to be ready and we need
to be laying ten years of groundwork so
they're ready to make one of the biggest
financial decisions of their life as 80
you call this financial literacy did you
prefer to call it something else I think
when people hear the term financial
literacy they think about things that
happen in schools and what I'm talking
about is what goes on at home because if
you believe as I do that there's a
direct connection between talking about
money and teaching kids values you don't
want to outsource that to a teacher even
the the teacher and a you know calculus
is not school safe right no this is
something that you want to be in charge
of yourself and you want to be doing the
download because you want your kids to
stand for some of the same things that
you
is the fact that we've become cashless
that you can charge so many things make
it harder for kids to feel connected and
understand money my kids don't even see
it that often it is and it's true and
you want to look for opportunities so
that they can see you know sort of the
visceral use of actual green Cash Money
in your everyday grown-up life but as
kids we want them to be collecting
allowance over many years you know five
six seven eight in coins and in green
cashville so they can count it they can
watch it grow they can see it happen and
then maybe they can go virtual after
that what if the number so if it's good
advice to tell our kids how much we make
what if the number is gargantuan you
know I was talking to a guy who works in
finance a few weeks ago makes a
gazillion girl told me he makes 20
million dollars a year what happens if
you tell your kids that you make 20
million dollars a year chances are if
you make that money they're going to
find out you figured that out already
already right because you really want
them seeing that number on a playground
20 million how you like me now no you
don't but you don't tell them until
they're ready and readiness happens over
the course of a decade but the issue
with having a lot of money right is if
you have that kind of money if the kids
Google your name they're going to find
out stuff about you and it may not be
right and if you're shutting them down
and not answering their questions
they're going to end up with the wrong
impression with the wrong information
and thinking that they need to turn to
the Internet to get their aunts wrong is
there one way that you found to
successfully imbue children with the
right values around money I think the
thing that I would focus on there is
helping your kids understand why it is
that you give the way that you give
assuming that you're a family that gives
at least some money away bring them in
on that conversation because the sort of
asset allocation of your charity of your
charitable budget says something about
who you are and what you stand for it if
you stopped to look at it that way you
may actually decide or your kids may
help you decide that it doesn't really
fit what the family stands for and it
may be time to do something a little
different